now that I like more on a Sunday that
some old guys spewing f-bombs
this guy is should not be president
period and when you say that folks on
Fox come after you
I remember the Tonys when he got up
there and cursed a lot of doesn't move
you okay well you know this is kre so
it's not an FCC violation but it is
still a Sunday morning ah
that was Bobby DeNiro promoting his new
movie grumpy old man Seven Dwarfs
strained Peas actually he's triggered by
our nation's hall monitor brian Stelter
asking him about fox news for some
reason the host acts dumb not a stretch
as if he didn't see this coming from a
guy who talks like a one-man Navy this
idiot is the president the guy is a fool
our government today with the prompting
of our baby and chief has been chief I
call him that some reliable source you
got there this is what moms call bad
language or what producers call great TV
the plan get an irrational figure at
peaked arrangement and go to MIT is
snapping
it's like cabaret for the chronically
obsessed it's like when you were a kid
and would pull wheelies on old man
Johnson's Frankie yard
finally just cracks he's holding a
spatula chasing you around in his open
robe
that's the DeNiro CNN business model in
a nutshell money for nothing and clicks
for free of course the real story is how
accusations of Trump's nutty behavior
always ends up with the accusers acting
nuttier DeNiro calls Trump crazy as he
goes crazier Adam Schiff calls Trump a
liar as he makes up quotes dams talk
about undermining institutions as they
try to undermine an election but when
asked for reasons why Trump shouldn't be
President all Bobby had were sputtering
f-bombs his resistance had run out of
scrip it was just another roll without
dialogue so he had to improvise but I
handed to CNN it got me to watch and by
having it on the five at quadrupled
their audience Congrats the Stelter and
CNN for that one minute you had a hit so
I show a Danish I quote Scott Adams oh
yeah I was thirsty okay
right he claims that that because that
we've entered a new phase we're not
liking Trump is just a lifestyle so
you're a lifestyle resistor because when
you yes so when he kept saying why why
it's like when you run out of words and
you can't explain anything anymore and
it's because they think you're too dumb
to understand like if you have to ask
the question then clearly you're just
not smart enough to understand why he
shouldn't be president yeah that's like
in his mind they were the weird thing
about the f-bomb stuff is that he's
clearly doing it on purpose and he has
enough self-control I would imagine to
not drop f-bombs but they're doing it
for effect as if it works so who else
did that recently better O'Rourke yes
he's out there he's dropping the f-bomb
everywhere to the point that ABC had to
say by the way not gonna be allowed on
our debate stage not gonna allow that
and I quote him we just might do it
anyway yeah also I just wonder about
Robert DeNiro because it does seem like
he's either playing himself or a
character or it could be just the same
thing now yeah it is to say this is a
role the resister is the role now and
he's comfortable in the role and he's
starting the role though I will say this
Donna I am Pro swearing I don't know why
we have to be so worried about those
words and maybe it's cuz I don't have
kids but I find swearing to be very
valuable thing you know I spent most of
my childhood and I would say almost half
a mile dull who going to church on
Sunday confessing to using swear words
so I try to avoid them although I've
been known to make complete sentences
out of sweat but not on this show this
this potty mouth stuff I don't think
it's good TV Emily I think it's rude
it's offensive and and that's why we
have to accent this weekend don't take
the bait when the president was tweeting
out things calling Democrat savages
I said don't take the bay be bass I
always use the first lady you know
hashtag be bass we all try to be at our
best when we're dealing with these
topics could could party mouth be a
medical condition Tourette's
yeah that's when you
[Laughter]
yeah I think there's something to be
said of course swearing feels really
good and it kind of blows off steam but
that's usually privately and there's
obviously the stronger argument for in
the national conversation and public
discourse we want you to be able to use
your words and have that specificity and
rise above it especially for those
running for office and whatnot
I personally appreciated that Bobby Dee
doubled down and instead of apologizing
that like literally his response to
Brian saying so you know for you like
kind of unleashing that tirade that was
his response to that he doubled down
that being said he's a larger-than-life
celebrity nothing will ever touch Bobbie
Dee I think everybody should see it
because they shot a big scene on my old
street in the West Village Pesci in it
it has pretty much any great actor in
any of those gangster movies that's
gonna be in it and I disagree with all
of you guys are being way too sensitive
he's old he doesn't care he's rich he
obviously Trump drives him crazy yeah so
I don't think it's about lacking
self-control I don't think he even wants
to control himself
my thing is I could care less about the
swearing what I find interesting is that
he couldn't come up with a reason not
and so it's like and that's where you
run into a lot of people like this that
when you're talking to me to go okay
just tell me and they can eat go then
they run away the question was you know
what do you have to say if people watch
Fox News and criticize you and he goes I
don't care who criticizes yeah that's
all that matter that yeah I mean I'm
kind of sensitive what the office of the
presidency regardless who to occupant
and I think you know to have someone you
know use that word in conjunction with
the office of the presidency I have a
decency standard I mean I may dislike
the fact your holiness isn't saying that
about the president that was a couple
weeks before agency standard baby I need
to go to confession with too much to
deal with
pretty it takes hours by the way ou have
to lay down a tarp okay